et même rené va poser des questions sur
koh lanta 1 et sparrow ni leur juste
niveau
j'ai jamais regardé je ne regarde jamais
nui se tiendra samedi
ça m'a coûté et sape les friches et 10 k
way academy la whey et jaune reçu par
papa et elle travaille elle si elle s'y
m'appelle et me dit oh la vie et tu vas
faire tous les bars je crois que match
tu as benzema ont fait leurs patins dès
qu'elles savent pas contre dany tu vas
faire tous les bars étaient plutôt
contents mais moi je sais pas qui
c'était enfin j'aime avoir rêvé cela une
bomba
bah ouais ça sera assis au comptoir du
bar la lafa me dit allez on va combattre
le choléra et bernad deux stars de la
barre mais bon on ne peut pas trop
compagne un coup je compte pas que cela
m'amuse pas qui c'est et moi je dirai
qui tu es toi hein et me dit tu voulais
pas connaître les mêmes cotes a qualifié
l'émission en direct y avait plus de
grand n'est pas l'avis de mourir
[Rires]
non
voilà qui va retenir toi